this is a disaster
[Music]
we live in a culture full of stuff
bombarded with advertisements pushing us
to buy more stuff we accumulate more and
more and more until we need an extra
storage unit to fit it all today there
are more self storage facilities in the
US than there are McDonald's subway and
jack-in-the-box restaurants combined I
heard about minimalism a few years back
and it was something that really piques
my interest minimalism is a lifestyle
movement of living with less material
items there's a whole community of
people living this way and connecting
online you have all different types of
people seems like a really beautiful way
to live your life I have one friend who
just lives out of a tiny little duffel
bag and he's ready to travel at the drop
of a dime I think it's always good to
have less and only have the essentials I
mean I think it's easy that makes it
easier because it's hard to have more
things help is me can't allow me to find
some of that freedom for myself there
are these two guys kind of like at the
forefront of this movement on social
media they're called the minimalist I
made this Netflix documentary called
minimalism I got the minimalist to come
into the studio and ask them some
questions about how I could start my own
minimalist journey what are some
guidelines for living a minimalist life
minimalism is not about deprivation it's
about bringing what is important and I
think really what it comes down to is
what is adding value to one's life for
everyone that's different
yeah and it's always changing we've got
a lot of clutter even if we do a really
good job organizing it it's still
organized hoarding I have a 1990 rule
where if I haven't used something in the
last 90 days and I don't plan on using
it in the next 90 days I'll probably get
rid of it what advice you have for me
well I do this experiment I get really
clear on why you're doing it I think we
all understand the hell - I do feel
somewhat attached to my items through
the experiment I really want to let go
of that I don't want to empty out my
room right now what to get myself into
what I quickly started to realize is
that I've been holding on to stuff for
years I consider myself to be someone
who's pretty frugal and it's not that I
was buying more stuff it was that I
hadn't been letting go
anything I'm overflowing in yoga pants
after going through everything I
realized I have a lot more stuff than I
thought I did
here's the breakdown 14 pieces of wall
decor 55 books 25 candle / trinkets 13
journals 53 makeup items 123 beauty /
hygiene products 24 pairs of shoes 15
purses and bags 22 miscellaneous
accessories and more than 300 items of
clothing I decided to box everything up
shove it in a storage closet and at the
end of the week I could decide what I
want to keep and what I want to donate
all that I'm really left with is work
stuff laptop my bed I'm not moving
furniture because I know it but I
emptied everything out of it for the
next week I would live with only the
essentials this included a hat and
armband and headphones for running my
yoga mat a foam roller my water bottle
one book a small bag a binder fall very
important documents and my speaker I
cannot live without my speakers I listen
to music every single day my meditations
on here and I use it for my yoga
practice this gratitude journal was
hidden underneath like 10 other journals
and I completely forgot that I have this
I'd also write in my gratitude journal
every night I limited myself to only
essential hygiene products like a
toothbrush and toothpaste face wash soap
and deodorant makeup would not be
considered essential I picked out enough
yoga clothes and workout clothes to get
me through the week just so I wasn't
doing a ton of laundry and then a few
key items of regular clothing mostly
dresses just because they are easy and
make you look the most put together with
minimal work the cluttering is merely
the first step the real purpose of
minimalism has to do with the benefits
we experience once we're on the other
side of the decluttering so I thought
that after I emptied my room I would
feel empty but I feel really good
looking around my room and seeing how
clear it is it's nice I'm feeling
optimistic about this week I'd like to
see if this experiment would allow me to
free up my time a little bit more I'm
gonna time myself and see how fast I can
get ready
minutes in 23 seconds and I am out the
door on my way to work
here's what no makeup but yeah I'm not
gonna be late I thought I would feel a
little bit I'm deep walking into an
empty room after a day of work it's kind
of refreshing it really is look at this
beautiful van beautiful what's his name
Oscar her name Oscar I love that name so
I met this guy Jim when I was walking
down the street he was in this really
cool green van and it looked like he was
living out of the band so I stopped and
asked him hey like what's your story
said that he had given up his life kind
of go travel and live out a vent I love
this thing
it's so great oh I get one how did you
find this lifestyle and what did you
give up to live this way I gave up like
my career at the time which was a
restaurant owner I had two restaurants
in a cocktail bar my minimalism
lifestyle started when I sold my house I
said like a 3,500 square-foot house with
tons of stuff in it slowly but surely I
eliminated in limited stuff and it's not
like I I watched a documentary write a
book about it it's just it it was just
something that came out of me naturally
the goal of it all was just to live a
life of not being encumbered with it but
not just with things but with timetables
and schedules and appointments and
expectations so it's only day three and
I'm already having to do
because I didn't account for the fact
that I would need pair of underwear for
working out and yoga and had a pair of
underwear for actually wearing so I
already ran out of clean underwear kind
of like going on a date tonight and kind
of date I don't know if it's eight
whatever I can't really put on any
makeup and starting to get a pimple
right here
so this is what minimalism starts to be
not fun for me
at first it was nice not having to
choose I'm gonna wear now I'm really
bummed that I like can't choose I really
feel like a slob today Ryan do you think
I look like a slob the minimal is life
is not thank you I'm on my way to Santa
Monica to interview this woman who I met
through minimalist org where they have
like all these community meet up groups
in every major city and so I just hit up
the one for LA I'm going to talk to her
because I want to get a female
perspective about this lifestyle for me
I think one of the biggest things has
been just like not wearing makeup
letting go of some clothing and living
with very few pieces of clothing so I
feel like I am a little lost in like how
I put myself together every day I would
say that my face is very well curated so
everything that I have in here I love it
or it has some sort of story behind it
or serve some sort of purpose if not
more than one purpose you don't have any
clothes how do you feel as a female how
do you feel like it's affected your
expression if it has if I don't love it
or feel really good in it it does not
say in my closet were you somebody who
always wore makeup and was attached to
like that kind of stuff I like makeup
like I like to feel pretty and a lot
more intentional about the makeup
products that I have and then I own I
have this
you have minimalism in my head I think
what I started this like you learned
that oh it doesn't have to be so extreme
you very I don't get your own I really
think that our material possessions are
a physical manifestation of what's going
on inside us
once I started dealing with that
external clutter I was able to deal with
what was going on inside of me the
mental clutter the emotional clutter the
spiritual clutter of the financial
clutter this internal clutter what I
learned this week is that there's no
right way to live a minimalist lifestyle
but that it did add a lot of value in my
life and freedom to live with a lot less
material items
I think I'm somebody that is too messy
and gets too sweaty to live with so few
clothing items although I do think I'm
gonna end up donating a lot of my
clothes along with a lot of my other
material possessions and I love the way
my room is now with it being so simple I
felt like my head space was a lot
clearer I was able to get out more meet
more people and live more in the moment
I'm writing in my gratitude journal and
it can't talk because I had my retainer
in I am grateful for my retainer no I'm
just kidding I mean I am grateful for
this because it keeps my teeth straight